Alexa it's your third week of Game Spot
it's my third week of Game Spot we're
very excited to have you on here doing
video game spotting uh Mary Kish you've
been here for a really long time hey
how's I've been here nobody cares
anymore nobody greets me anymore I don't
get excited you're old news Kish it'll
change Alexa they won't they won't get
excited forever yeah we're glad to have
you it's exciting I'm excited to be here
and you're jumping right into it cuz
it's like November and there's so many
games so many games all the games came
out all of them came out nober one of
the big games you just reviewed actually
Tales just reviewed tals what something
something the Borderlands I totally said
it wrong before the break and you
corrected me but now I have also
forgotten it again tals from the
Borderlands so it's from the Borderlands
not of the Borderlands and uh the
Borderlands you gave this game a nine I
did give this game a nine it is superb
superb game I want to talk about this
because it's a weird one I'm a
Borderlands fan uh but like it's a
Telltale Game it's it's you're making
story choices uh H how do you make a
game that's like really all about like
running around and blasting things and
picking up Loot and then blasting more
things into like a a Telltale Game so
the thing about the thing about Telltale
is Telltale creates these really big
epic stories from like microcosms of
people so they take Ordinary People
granted maybe the fables weren't that
ordinary but they take Ordinary People
and then they tell these like amazing
Stories and the reason that Tales from
the Borderlands works as a narrative
thing is because um the characters
they're not Vault Hunters they're not
they have no special powers whatsoever
they're not even that cool they're like
normal ass people living in the freaky
Borderlands Town yes living in freaky
Borderlands town and the guy works for
Hyperion the mega Corporation and the
girl is a grifter and they're just
trying to get by and trying to like do
right by themselves and get what they
think they deserve and that makes a
really interesting story so so much of
the Borderlands world is like like it's
got character right it's got I mean it's
it's color ful there's all sorts of
strange creatures and all sorts of weird
people whose dialogue is amusing or
terrifying or whatever uh B Lance too
did that really well uh is it does this
does that carry through here I mean it's
a different writing team it's not from
it's not gearbox it's not anyone who has
worked on Border Lines before so did
they I imagine that that sort of did
they capture yes is it funny funny it is
hilarious it's so funny there are some
moments with uh some of the characters
and like this like like okay so there's
an opening scene where there is a like
you build a loader bot and you spend
it's like this big high octane thing
where people are rushing you to like
build it hurry up and you're like
actually selecting what goes on it while
people are fighting Bandits and it like
pops up and it's this big like like
crazy scene where it like builds itself
and it say epic music and everything
goes silent and it just goes hi and like
it's funny it's funny we're starting now
hey guys this is just my life but like
but like it's funny like there are there
and there's like little like
conversational gems like the banter
between the characters is really well
done like I love the dialogue it's very
much a Telltale Game but it's definitely
Borderlands humor interesting no it does
it's totally funny May you've played a
bunch of Borderlands yeah it's just such
a confusing thing for me to play in this
world and yet not be loot focused it's
very confusing for me when I play these
games when I get excited about
Borderlands I think I can't wait to get
that next freaking gun I can't wait to
test it out I'm going to get like the
best gun I can find but there's no loot
in this game what am I doing what is my
reason to exist it's uh it's emotional
loot Mary what it's emotional loot
purple and emem R
emotions so there are like some very
specific instances where yeah you're
picking up money off of people that you
may or may not have like smacked to the
ground and then taken all their good so
there is some traditional looting um but
the reward that you get here is uh the
way that they've sort of structured the
dialogue for recent Fiona the two main
characters they've written it so that
they are two people that are telling
their sides of a story so you don't know
like there is literally no right or
wrong answer you are crafting their
story like crafting who they are as a
character because they're literally
blank slates with different options you
do shoot a gun what's it like is it does
it go bang uh we have very rudimentary
understanding of video games here so you
can you can shoot a gun if you'd like to
shoot a gun as with Telltale everything
is a matter of choice so without
spoiling okay yeah cuz and so that's the
key thing with Telltale uh you know and
they're sort
of the Walking Dead which was you know
Game of the Year at so many places so
many people loved it I I'm pretty sure
you're a huge fan of it oh yeah uh that
it was the choices that sort of defined
each episode but then defined the whole
Arc uh so I guess when you're sort of
you know when you're talking about
fables for example their more more
recent game there's a defined Arc
there's a story there that they're kind
of following within this world and sort
of things happen uh that you know are
touch points that they maybe include or
maybe they go a different way but with
tails from of the Borderlands you
they're the challenge for them is to
help you see that Arc for the five
episodes but then also make the first
episode satisfying did that happen yes
um the way that they've done it uh
they've done the first episode is
there's sort of like so the episode has
a boss in it without again spoiling
there is a boss character that you
actually confront in some way I feel
like that's a that's a Borderlands thing
you're going to have some big bad weirdo
that you got to get by and their big bad
weirdo is amazing he's like this guy
they've shown him in the trailers he's
got a he's called bosan NOA and he has a
speaker on his chest and he speaks
like like he like garbles like metal
rock or whatever and then one time you
come upon him and it's not on and he has
this like high pitch squeaky voice so he
like and he's bluring techno it's really
cool um so Space Balls it's very it's
very Space Balls you take off this giant
helmet and you're just little little
loser Rick Moranis he's the Rick Moranis
of CH from the Borderlands um but no
there are some very big there's like two
very distinct action sequences and they
action sequences in a sense that like
you are constantly moving maybe not you
know shooting and looting but you're
moving a lot and moving very quickly I
think uh for me it's it was a they were
scenes that moved more quickly than like
the scenes in The Walking Dead where
you're like moving through zombies or
the scenes in The Wolf Among Us where
you're beating up someone frogs frogs
beating up frogs so it was uh I think
they did it really well they had a
really nice like sort of two point two
high points like two climactic arcs
about how long is the first episode two
and a half hours mhm so not very long at
all but is that the kind of The Telltale
thing I don't know they stick with 90
minutes usually it's around 90 minutes a
little more than that so this one I
think uh it was long but I think it did
it ended at the right Point like it did
a good job setting it up so now these
remaining four episodes can really like
really do the fun five there's five
complete and it's interesting they they
let you know from the GetGo um what
you're in for in terms of how much
content you'll be getting yeah do you
know when the next one's coming out no
usually usually they come out like with
Walking Dead and the Wolf Among Us it
was usually maybe a month and a half to
almost two months in between episodes
like this is like they develop live like
this episode was probably finished last
week and then they decided okay we're
going to release it next week they're
still working on um working on episode
two so Telltale does the live
development thing where they release the
episode when it's ready it's not all
done and they're just holding it back
and waiting to release it what an
emotional roller coaster yeah emotional
loot do you think the tension of
developing on such a deadline really
feeds into the creating those action
sequence tensions well now that they
have Borderlands and Game of Thrones
which is coming like very soon they've
got the new game they're making their
own Game of Thrones which is sort of
like it get it has a character that is
sort of in the book and it's touch going
to involve like like we saw leaked
screenshots of Cersei Lannister T Tyrion
uh you know those characters actually
raised a question to me did you like
meet anyone in Borderlands Tales from
from the Borderlands that you knew or is
that a spoiler you don't want to go into
so the name of the episode is zero some
okay and zero of course Vault hunter
from warlands 2 yeah and zero is in it
and zero uh is Zero's scenes are really
really funny like they're probably some
of the best written scenes in this in
the episode humor uh tense action
emotional loot emotional loot sounds
pretty cool uh if you folks want to know
more about it Alexa review is up on
Gamespot right now you can check it out
uh and that's Tales from the
Borderlands